完了喽，
我们来水杯了，
姐姐准备好租金，
我今天准备把这里盘下来，
解开门，
我们来了，
姐姐吃什么呀？
那猪蹄女猪蹄儿姐内分高，
因为我平时跟你们在一起显得我太矮了，
这个整体的面积你给你来展示一下，
真能踩那么高吗？
9cm看好啊，
上一次倒个楼梯是吧，
小迷米啊，
这自己看我买了什么好东西，
这什么，
这个直接挂在我那个后面墙上，
我就不用这样到非常醒目，
对，
粘上去，
粘到后面我那直播墙上的那个，
哎，
这个包包，
不是说我这个包包很好吗？
我给你一个卷卷，
一人买一个39块钱包太好了吧，
我来了，
所以说你包给你个这好了吧，
39块。
知道我喜欢黑色啊，
我的是一个小小鸡华，
我觉得我的最好看，
我散粉散，
想补个散粉吗？
散粉用你是怕出游碰见人借卷卷的伞，
没用这样起手，
关键是我出门没有带卷卷，
出门带了，
这很关键，
因为卷卷今天嗯，
化了点妆可以了吗？
嗯，
可以了啊啊，
没有油光了，
压住了，
这样的话遇到的姐妹们我不怕合照的，
不去合照的师不是去水贝得多久啊呃，
三十几分钟哦好，
我们今天打算去水贝去炒货，
我们去逛逛，
不是都说那儿的金子便宜吗？
就是我们应该在网上先问一下砍价应该是什么风格，
先查一下攻略，
比如说是砍1/3还是砍1/2，
还是腰斩，
就上次咱那个华强北。
的架子鼓，
回来一搜机会，
我上次买那个架子鼓260买的嘛啊，
回来过一搜100多块钱，
我现在有经验了，
我要买什么东西的时候你俩先拦着我，
行，
咱先搜一下自姐我们先看一看，
早上向要走了，
好了，
哈喽，
我们来水费啦，
嗯，
姐姐准备好租金，
我今天准备把这里盘下来，
结果手上好像缺个金镯子，
走走走人咋了，
你想把你的什么东西还有个还也不能强全不么叫人家哇，
还有个类似于这种大的金坠装，
觉得当初我对象追我的时候给我买的，
自从他把钱上交了之后，
我就再也没有买过了，
就是钱一旦到我手里了，
就不舍得买，
给你们挑着挑着节目给。
你挑起来了，
太适合我了吧，
发财我在京东上买了一个银啊，
买了1000g，
花了13000多块钱，
因为他现在说他可以给我回收17块钱一克，
不是17块多左右，
17块多啊，
当天的上价我就没有干嘛，
但是我议你当时买的时候一小大真的心动，
但是不买，
这个是珍珠的哈，
珍珠这个多少钱，
那就给你100块钱，
手链的话基本上就要在这个大格就比较合适一些，
嗯，
这个稍微贵一点，
这个价可能一点点好，
这个我们拿多天按80多吗？
你要看你拿多少，
这个细细珍珠这个价格已经给你打3000，
我感觉还是玉的吧，
昨点这个吧，
这个感觉润一点，
这个我要是拿十串儿，
你能不能100块钱一串给我。
120，
我就看你拿的头给你，
我不后续肯定还要去拿的，
这确定是和田玉啊，
肯定你给我来20串，
100块钱一串行不行？
2我们会去，
肯定还要拿别的了，
跟我来马岩行行，
先去逛一下吧，
我要先去逛一下，
我们还没逛完呢，
你考虑一下，
我一会儿再回来，
快留住我真走了，
真走了，
遇见他怎么没留我演技不行，
我的妈呀，
要不然下次真遇到粉丝了，
你拿什么送到牙一块九一百三看到没没买，
我们最后再回去，
我们再去别的店看一下，
买二十二十个，
听他们说这边都是不行的，
230个能看，
我刚才差点就说出来了，
我说买30个不行不行不行，
我们再去多家店对比一下，
其实我们是不是也可以再买，
好像是啊，
但是我大买，
我不能保证他是和田玉啊，
你在这儿他也不一定是和田玉啊，
但是最重要就是老板信誓旦旦的说是和田玉啊，
我们是在。
就这样，
不是亲我的哟，
他会叫你一声亲，
那怎么办？
我们又没有人认识和田玉，
不知道怎么间间谍，
我们去那边看一下吧，
那边有散电好吧，
是手机贴，
还是有钱花，
很有寓意啊啊，
我买的多没有买的多也是10块啊，
就个可以就买得起，
行，
那就这样买一些，
我们选一些好不好很好的，
马上有钱，
马上发财，
招财令有钱花哦不顺顺顺顺顺放不好，
他们还可以选一下，
123456买10个吧姐，
就放你包里吧，
你刚刚那个便宜，
刚买完，
我们再买几个八腰裤不是再低价买入，
拉平大杠给拉平一下吧姐哦，
我再买10个。
23456789，
买十个吧，
送你一个我一个是吧，
会给你吧，
我一个多好，
小姐有钱，
送我一个好姐券，
不仅价格低，
人家还多送你一个，
这个多少钱？
这应该45块，
但这个我们不好携带，
这个不好携带，
2块9毛9，
第一次逛水杯，
总结一下经验和教训吧，
不要轻易出手，
嗯，
我们发现我们第一次出手的时候10块钱，
第二次我就发现不么远的地方有人卖了5块钱，
然后我们果断的买了，
这样的话拉平一下我们的投资距离，
我们买了什么呢？
还是有收获的，
等你们下次遇到我的时候就知道了。
我今天很冲动，
哎，
我想买那个和田玉来着，
但是卷卷拦住了我，
主要我们也不知道那是不是和田玉。
这看起来就跟我对差不多，
确实我们不认识，
还好没有冒险。
嗯，
今天还是没有人认识我们，
好像是，
哦，
哎呀，
太遗憾了。